ce que nous voulons aider c'est l'emploi
des moins qualifiés de nos compatriotes
en bas de l'échelle salariale ou les
boosts c'est sûr qu'ils vont faire les
voir baisser les charges pour à toute
force les faire rentrer dans la
dynamique de l'emploi de l'insertion
nous croyons à quoi nous croyons qu'il
n'y a pas de vie épanouie pas de vie
heureuse sans le travail et que le
travail n'est pas une animation que le
travail est une émancipation que tout
doit partir du travail que l'homme et la
femme que l'être humain le sommes faits
pour deux choses et mes et travaillez
travaillez l'épée mais que c'est le
coeur du message que le nom